have you seen that image on reddit it's
just like the little baby three of us
[ __ ] love that image man
finally i'm as tall as you guys
the only time is actually gonna be as
tall as us yeah exactly i saw some guy
making his phone wallpaper
thanks guys
but yeah you don't you guys probably
haven't seen any like you guys probably
haven't felt any break we felt a massive
break this is six weeks
six weeks since we last recorded which
to me has felt like six months right
yeah yeah like aged one year since i saw
you guys
that's crazy
oh my god um but yeah like sir if you
didn't know me and connor went back to
the uk yeah uh for like three four weeks
and then we had two weeks of quarantine
so basically scheduling that out it
comes out to about six weeks before we
last recorded
um it has been like since we started
trash taste i didn't realize how much my
schedule relied on me going to trash
taste and just seeing the boys because
like it was weird just not seeing seeing
the both of you like every week i was so
bored during september not gonna lie
like while you guys were gone like every
tuesday i was getting ready to go i was
like oh
i don't have to honey i'm going to work
i'm going to work jk
oh we have our coffees yes oh finally
finally thank you
so yeah we went back to the uk that was
fun yeah how was it that was good i mean
how long has it been like two years
right almost since you guys might have
two years yeah it's been it's been about
two years so it's been two years
basically since i've seen any of my
mates there or my parents or my family
wasn't emotional
did you guys hug it out yeah it was
weird seeing my parents really
because it was just like i've only seen
them through zoom for like two years and
it was just kind of like right right
yeah yeah it was weird having
conversations with people not through a
discord call or the zoom call because
you realize i i've forgotten what it was
like to just actually catch up with
someone not through a computer like damn
look at those graphics
i can touch them
when i went back to wales i felt like
the pope going around a small town i was
like hi guys i'm my parents yes come on
give me a hug
i'll give you i'll take a picture with
you parents
i'm kidding
i don't know
it's uh it was nice i uh i also learned
from my past mistakes of when i used to
go back home um i actually like try to
schedule as many hangouts with friends
as possible right i reached out to as
many people as possible yeah because
the last time i went home i just kind of
thought yeah i'll figure it out when i
get there and i ended up like not doing
anything like half days and i was like
[ __ ] i really should have yeah i i uh i
did the same thing as you and then i i
think i i made another mistake and i
think i planned two months oh yeah then
because because then then i i kind of
realized about like five six days in
like not even like halfway through my
trip
seeing someone every day you haven't
caught up to someone for two years what
do they want to do like crack open some
beers or a bottle of wine you just like
you end up just eating and drinking like
[ __ ] every single day and so you
basically downloaded the alcoholic dlc
basically so i was there for
20 days and
only
one day i didn't drink
jesus every single day i had at least
one beer or something right just because
that was like the thing yeah so i think
that you do in the uk yeah i think 70 to
80 of my schedule for my days there were
seeing someone or catching up with
someone yeah so and uh that that meant
70 to 80
of my trip was like
having some sort of drink yeah yeah yeah
do you drink with your parents yeah yeah
yeah so your parents are drinking as
well right yeah
my parents don't drink but since we
haven't drank anyway no no but since we
haven't drunk in two years they like
they brought open a bottle of wine and
they had a glass i was just like oh [ __ ]
okay oh it's special this is a special
occasion
like i think i've seen my mum drunk
before this once in my life and it was
for like my cousin's wedding yeah it's
just just the weirdest [ __ ] thing
right because my mom's like my mom is
like
as far as my perception is like the
biggest straight edge there is right she
doesn't drink she you know doesn't smoke
doesn't do anything like that i had
never ever seen her like in my life i
think i've seen her like take a sip of
alcohol about like i think five times in
my life total total um and then i
remember going to my cousin's wedding
and uh my entire family were there um
everyone had like flown in from thailand
so it was a rare occurrence that we have
a massive family gathered in one place
and it was the first time i'd seen
like a different side of my mum like i
had no idea
i had no idea that there was just this
monster
playing with it
right
and
it felt like it felt like almost like
she she got more drunk than sydney on
the day she got drunk faster than sydney
and that that gives you an indication of
like
how surprised i was right and i remember
like halfway through the wedding
um i i come sit i i come sit down and my
mom and dad are just sitting on this
table
my mom has a glass of wine in front of
us
um
and i i i don't know how much you're
drunk at this point and she was like
gig oh my my name's geek he's like gig
do you want you want to see me down this
glass of wine i was like
no no no mom i don't want to see you
mom no she was like i'll do i'll do it i
was like mom no no no don't do it and
she just
i was like mom
what what are you 15 what did what are
you 18.
meanwhile there's like six bottles of
wine
dance floor like this this is like 10 10
11 p.m see was on the dance floor just
like you know she was she was uh sydney
was like pretty not sober but she was
like mary you know she wasn't completely
drunk and then my mom just comes up to
her takes takes the bottle of um beer
that she's drinking just doubts it in
front of her and takes it gives it back
to her i've never seen sydney so
dumbfounded in my life
that's awesome but yeah so so yeah
i ended up drinking with my parents a
bit more which was a very rare
occurrence so of course of course i'm
gonna share some alcohol with them but
about like the fifth day in your body's
just like please please no more like
please i just like i i i like the social
aspect but my god my body just died like
halfway through the trip i think jesus
damn yeah i don't know i i just i was a
thing where especially in with my family
they drink quite often
so i feel like they saw it as an excuse
to drink more than usual yeah so then it
become a thing where i was like this is
great but i'm dying
my my dad's retired as well now so yeah
now he he loves it he's just like yeah i
i thought my dad would get bored being
retired he seems like i thought he was
one of those guys that really needed
like a job to keep him like occupied but
yeah he [ __ ] loves it he just gardens
all day and he loves it it's like he's
like he's life isn't it yeah
and i'm like oh [ __ ] like buying a canoe
who buys a canoe that's like what even
store a canoe like i didn't even keep
that i don't even know the logistics
behind owning a canoe seem way too
difficult
yes but i mean like seems like he's uh
loving it and uh yeah so it's nice it
was at least he's picked hobbies that
are going to keep him active yeah yeah
there's other things you could he could
have invested in true yeah
he occasionally does do work he does
like helps a friend with houses building
stuff i don't know
yeah for me that's all like that's
that's i mean that's just like chilling
that's just retiring that's a vibing
dude that's just simon right there yeah
that's where i want to be when i retire
yeah uh yeah i it was it was fun i went
back and forth between wales and london
it was a lot of fun
um got to see as many friends as
possible and drink way too much alcohol
we do that's kind of i mean like because
uh we posted a few pictures while we
were on like breaking the uk but i
remember like
i remember we were catching up with a
bunch of our friends and i actually
hardly ever talked to connor yeah in our
trip i mean we did we we obviously like
talked and caught up and everything but
we mostly spent time with like just
catching up with
other people i don't feel the need to
talk to you guys yeah yeah we see each
other everywhere i [ __ ] talk to you
way too much
i feel like we had a mutual
understanding that couldn't escape you
of like we've talked every week for like
the past [ __ ] over a year now yeah we
could have a little bit time apart and i
think i think the only times that we did
do something together was uh i think we
played like a game of chess
when i was drunk
we were both drunk
and uh and of course you beat me um
you're the only time when there was
unfortunately there's no one no cameras
no one watching the next chess
tournament should should have a blood
alcohol level measured before and you
need to be x amount required to play
that's what we need to disqualify if
it's below 0.7 but you're a little too
sober for my liking that's like you're
not in you're right there's so many
brains every time you lose a piece
you've got to do a shot or something i
don't know just just die yeah this this
is what chess needs the next evolution
from casual chess to just absolute
abhorrence
i also like playing chess again i
remember playing chess against you
because we had like we had a physical
board none of this you know none of this
online chess business we're in old
school and uh
we even had like a chess clock and
everything like that and uh i think i've
realized how much i've relied on like
the chess.com ui to really like oh it's
very good at the game because because
otherwise you have to look down like
this right because because i i was
pretty interested at that point but i
remember i fell for like the most
obvious checkmate of all time oh yeah
and uh and like and i i was like i was
trying to question how i couldn't see
that because we bet 20 pounds on the
game
i don't know why we bet 20 pounds on the
game i thought was like drunk at the
time
but uh whenever whenever i'm like
playing games with friends i'm like 10
bucks
let's make it interesting let's do it
let's have fun